Speaker 1: Let's go to the audience via discord
at David Pacman dot com slash discord and
hear what is on the minds of the people the
minds of the people.
We will go first.
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly, too.
Teresa of Minnesota, is that correct?
Tressa.
Speaker 2: Well, I pronounce it.
Theresa.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Theresa, Welcome.
Yes.
Speaker 2: Great.
Listen, I'm from Minnesota.
As you know, we are a blue state.
I am a Democrat.
I'm progressive.
I'm liberal.
I like to say that I will vote for Joe Biden
even if he is slumped over in a wheelchair
drooling because the GOP is that dangerous.
We know that the GOP bit part of their platform
so far has been big, heavy, anti trans transgender.
You know, they don't even want them to exist.
And they pull in a lot of suburban women when
they hear about children.
You know, children are being mutilated, blah,
blah, blah, which is not even true.
But, you know, the response from the left
seems to be dismissive.
Oh, they make up such a small minority of,
you know, demographic percentage of the demographic
of the population.
It's not even worth talking about.
And I kind of disagree.
And I have to point out that I like to talk
about.
Number one.
I don't know what it's like in other states,
but like I said, I live in Minnesota, a liberal
state and.
Corporations and companies and, you know,
board meetings and park boards and city council
meetings and knitting groups all start off
their meetings by asking people what their
names are and to declare your preferred pronoun.
I mean, this is there's not even a transgender
person in the room.
There might not be a transgender person in
a ten mile radius.
And it seems overboard, just like the GOP
goes overboard.
I think sometimes the left goes overboard.
I think the intentions are good.
You know, they want to be inclusive and accepting,
but asking someone what their pronouns are
is kind of intrusive.
I think someone.
Speaker 1: Might address this, Tricia, because
you've said a lot, and I don't want to forget
all the different points you made.
So first of all, from a very tactical level,
my opinion is I'm also against the unprovoked
putting forward of pronouns as a matter of
course, of of sort of standard operating procedure.
I know a number of teachers who teach in schools
where they started the year doing that, and
then they very quickly figured out, Hey, you
know what, this actually isn't great.
Number one, it's not great because the truth
is trans people are a very small part of the
population.
And so that why is it that we are doing this
absent any particular reason to do it Now,
one reason would be, well, you're making everyone
in the room comfortable because by by having
everyone state their pronouns, someone who
has pronouns that might not be obvious from
their physical appearance will be more comfortable.
The counterpoint to that, Marissa, is there
might be people in the group, in the audience,
in the room, whatever, who are currently struggling
with gender identity, who actually don't want
to be in the position to have to state.
Here are my pronouns.
So I would call it like it nets out to zero.
But my general view is I don't think that
that's something we need to be doing.
I'm very comfortable as a trans empathetic
and supportive individual, basically taking
my best guess at what people's pronouns are,
which, by the way, when you're talking to
the person, rarely even comes up.
It's usually when referring to the person,
to some other person.
But anyway, and if I get it wrong, it's very
obvious that I'm not doing it in bad faith
and someone can correct me and whatever.
So that's my view on the statement of Pronouns
piece.
Does that make sense to you?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Yes.
Triple yes.
Okay.
Yes to all of that.
Speaker 1: On the earlier thing you said,
Theresa, which was along the lines of.
There may be it may not be the best approach
to just say this isn't even a big enough issue
to talk about and dismissing it outright.
You're not big on that.
I think I understood.
Is that right?
Speaker 2: Correct.
Speaker 1: My thought on this is sort of as
follows.
We should recognize that it is no longer acceptable
to treat or stereotype.
That many groups that at one point was okay
to do.
Like there was a point in the United States
where it was just totally acceptable to use
the N-word when referring to black picked
black people, separate sinks, bathrooms, water
fountains and restaurants.
Okay, that's changed.
It's no longer acceptable to do that.
There was a point at which using the F-word
for gay people was acceptable and you could
openly discriminate.
That's not acceptable.
So what what's happening is that, A, the right
is going to smaller and smaller groups in
order to find someone that maybe they can
get away with scapegoating.
And I do think it's important to recognize
that we shouldn't overstate the prevalence
of trans people because like this happens
with anti-Semites.
Teresa If you ask some anti-Semites, listen,
what percentage of the population do you think
is even Jewish?
And sometimes they'll say five, ten, 20%,
and they go, you know, it's 0.2%, right?
So I do think it's good to be accurate about
the size of a population.
At the same time, I agree with you that just
saying it's not an issue because it isn't
a big population.
It's not a very that's not a super strong
defense.
I agree with you.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I don't think that it's a
small issue because when people are being
harmed, it's an issue.
Right.
You know, companies, whatever, can have their
diversity and inclusion policies.
I don't know.
Most companies have a handbook or whatever
make it very clear that there are consequences
and ramifications for P treating people disrespectfully
by not calling them by the name that they
wish to be called by.
Whether you think that name belongs to what
they look like or not.
Sure.
You know.
Yeah.
So it's not ignoring it, but not going overboard
the other way, which I think alienates a lot
of people.
Speaker 1: Teresa, can I mostly agree with
everything you're saying?
I know you had more, but I have so many people
waiting, and we've been on almost 10 minutes.
I want to keep getting people on, if that's
okay.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Teresa from Minnesota.
Very powerful stuff